[Music]
you must have seen that mom wears
beautiful soft and shiny saris on
special occasions the texture beauty and
the luster of the fabric grabs a lot of
attention and appreciation but what is
this fabric exactly it's nothing but
silk yes we have come across this term
several times let us now understand what
Circus and how the fibers are obtained
to start with can you tell me the source
of silk fibers is it a plant or any
animal it's an animal this small worm
called a silkworm gives us silk threads
but how can we get threads from such
tiny creatures and how many threads can
this little one give us let's get to
know the complete process by
understanding the silkworms lifecycle to
begin with the first stage is where the
eggs are laid by the female moth on
leaves which plant leaves are preferred
by the moths it is the leaves of plants
like mulberry which are preferred so the
X stage is the first stage the next
stage is where the eggs develop into
larvae larvae are forms that appear
somewhat like this yes
the worm-like structures the larvae grow
in size by feeding themselves on the
mulberry leaves so the growth in these
is gradual the growth stages of these
larvae are also given a scientific name
the stages are called in star in literal
terms in star means the phase between
the two molding processes of the insect
larva so in this case we can say the
larvae grow into first instar second
instar third and star and so on till
they feed themselves enough once the
larvae are content with the amount of
food consumed that is the leaves they
enter the next stage this stage is their
resting phase so for resting all we need
is a cozy cover around ourselves just
like the blanket that we take while
sleeping similarly even these larvae try
to make a cover around
them this is when they secrete slimy
thread-like structures from their mouths
they swirl their head in all directions
when secreting the threads as a result
of this movement a thick coat of threads
gets formed around the complete body
this coat is called the cocoon did you
know that this cocoon is what is of
great interest to us because it is this
structure that will give us the silk
threads after we process it once the
cocoon is formed the larva inside it
starts resting and enters the next stage
of its life cycle called the pupa stage
the pupa stage is where the organism is
sessile which means it does not usually
move and it starts developing the organs
which adult moths have so here the pupa
rests inside the cocoon and starts
developing into an adult after it
develops completely the next stage that
is the adult stage is reached the mature
moth is now ready to break the cocoon
and fly away this is the complete
lifecycle of a silkworm so now can you
tell me how silk is obtained from these
animals the cocoon is the main source of
the threads once the pupa develops into
an adult and flies away leaving the
cocoon behind the cocoons can be
collected and the threads are obtained
the threads in a cocoon are extremely
strong they are surprisingly as strong
as the threads the processing of these
threads further gives us the silk fibers
in short these are the four
developmental stages of a silkworms
lifecycle the eggs come first then the
larval stage followed by the pupil stage
and lastly the adult stage whether
mature moths fly out of the cocoon but
how and where do we get these cocoons
from do we have to go to the forests
where the mulberry trees are is there
any other way to get them the silkworms
are reared in special farms rearing of
these silkworms is a profitable industry
by itself the practice of culturing
south worms is called Sri culture
next we will see this beautiful practice
of sericulture and understand how third
fibers are obtained from the cocoons
[Music]
you